je suis pas une fête inoïta ni bon alors
espèce de
contre-exemple
alors après les pauvres et les riches
tiennent ce qu'il y a cette fois sans
prendre au classement moyenne ça
s'appelle Tati Daniel et il dit en
parlant d'elle c'est une vieille [ __ ]
qu'on aime c'est une vieille dame de
Provence qui a un petit peu de moyens et
qui quelqu'un qui s'occupe d'elle qui va
disparaître et qui va être prise en
charge par des bons gros gentils
en parlant de l'arrivée de Tatie
Danielle dans la famille la famille
billard toi tu es Catherine billard
l'esthéticienne pomponnet middlclass
comme ça fauchic impeccable
pour toutes avec son petit mari que
la cruauté la trivialité la protection
n'existe pas c'est une fiction qu'on
voit au cinéma ou dans les journaux
c'est de la fiction à l'armiste la
réalité n'existe pas autrement que par
les médias c'est un peu un personnage
comme notre célèbre Marie-Thérèse de la
vie c'est-à-dire écrasé par le écrasé
par le destin vict le destin et tu as
dit une chose formidable sur ton
personnage je te dis elle va elle va
s'en tirer mais elle sera marquée
durablement dans 10 ans elle sera
charmante mais elle prendra deux doigts
de Porto c'est
l'impression qu'elle s'en sort mais elle
est cassée quand même toujours assuré
une façon
sociale il y a même pas social toute
façon elle va toujours avoir la façade
comme ça mais c'est quelqu'un il sera un
peu moins télé comme ça et je serai
probablement quelqu'un qui va dériver
doucement
moi j'ai adoré toutes les parties où tu
es là avec Éric Pratt toutes les parties
dans la famille et puis un peu moins le
début un peu moins c'est un peu long sur
Sila Shelton tu trouves comment toi le
film
moi il faut que je leur envoie parce que
je l'ai vu l'autre jour dans un état
j'étais proche j'étais malade j'étais au
premier rang et c'est toujours très
troublant de se voir on se regarde un
peu trop le nombril alors je crois que
je vais le revoir tu as eu la vocation
quand tu étais petite tu habitais à
Compiègne et le dimanche ta maman
faisait des sorties de mini calme et
vous quittiez Compiègne pour aller à la
Comédie française c'est comme ça que tu
étais en contact
donc on est allé voir des gens mais
c'est vrai que ça ça a quand même
beaucoup joué de voir des gens comme
Pierre Charon reverrir je suis perdu
ça n'a pas été que ça il y avait aussi
la télé mais il y avait au cinéma mais
c'est vrai que c'est des gens comme ça
qui vous soufflent peut-être qui et
quand tu as fait le
névroses
c'est pour faire comme les copains il y
a un truc
tu as pris des cours Florent tout ça non
ouais ouais
en expérience dans ta vie tu as fait 850
gosses et 80 appartements
mais moi je voulais pas dans le travail
qui se retrouve plus non il fallait
minimum
moi dans la journée j'écrivais je
regardais les mômes c'est-à-dire qu'au
bout d'un moment faut piger assez vite
il faut arriver à 8h30 donc ils sont
couchés on va les voir en fait un petit
zizi machin mais après
nous savons on voit qui sont les gens
socialement on les appartements
[Musique]
après tu as eu donc le César du meilleur
espoir féminin
parce que en général
non
faite de
de contre-exemple c'est vrai que le soir
du César c'est Dina Le Brigitte à qui a
annoncé
et c'est vrai que le soir du César au
moment de te lever comme ça tu t'es dit
il faut pas que je regarde la Jenny ça
va me fragiliser
je m'en fous et c'est vrai que il y a
des gens qui
oui il y a des gens qui
c'est le cinéma qu'on s'en fait parce
que elles sont toutes les images
complètement elle lui avait parlé à son
voisin je sais pas je veux dire j'en
sais rien moi j'ai rien contre les amis
je m'en fous mais je me suis dit faut
pas faut pas aller chercher la pression
qui sert à rien j'ai pas envie d'aller
regarder trois quatre officiers mais ça
c'est un truc qu'on apprend au théâtre
de ce côté là où est au théâtre il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui apprend en vie de
t'as pas de problème
ça t'emmerdé de monter sur cette scène
devant tout le monde là
pourquoi comment et puis s'en servir je
veux dire
on va rajouter des épaisseurs pour
Marie-Thérèse cicatrie est un peu
grassouillette c'est parmi plus mal pour
le personnage je m'en fous moi je sais
je sais que je peux perdre 10 kilos et
pour un micro c'est pas un problème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'insulte qui t'a fait le plus mal dans
ta vie
quelqu'un qui m'a dit que j'avais pas de
visage pas de corps pas de fraîcheur et
pas trop les sociales
dans le boulot parce que dans ce cas
monsieur comme ça il y a exactement
trois ans on dit ça alors quand on a une
femme une jeune et que enfin bon voilà
ça je crois que c'est mais ça a été très
utile
en toi ton avis
quelle chose négatif tu dirais sur toi
ah bon non non
le lieu où tu es incapable de faire
l'amour
ou de la télé
non parce que
déjà pensé
de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu